you like how are you today I'm doing
great Dan how are you where are you
today I'm at Kean University in New
Jersey got a little you know here with
Gatorade there beat the heat program
couple kind of high school the middle
aged kids doing some football drills and
getting ready for their summer practices
and kind of talking them about staying
hydrated it's the importance of getting
your electrolytes in during these summer
months when it's hot you're sweating all
over the place and just you know not
only for your performance on the field
to be at a higher level but also just
your general health this you know the
importance of staying hydrated
especially during these uh you know
these summer training camps could you
ever see yourself coaching when you're
done you know I I enjoy
I do enjoy coaching young kids and like
these kids these these eighth graders
you know high school kids you know just
because you know you you see the
improvements on a couple days of being
with them we did we do our Manning
passing Academy down in Louisiana and
you know when it's very hot also
drinking a lot of Gatorade but you see
these kids that come in their first days
their eighth and ninth graders they're
excited about playing football but you
know they just don't know their
mechanics and their drops and there are
three steps five step that you know
they're just kind of nervous and I don't
know a whole lot about it and then you
know you work with them you teach it and
all sudden on that last day you just
kind of say to hey let's do let's do a
five-step drop no plant the one ounce
there left they always going on and
they're doing it and you just you see
the improvements and you know there's
teaching them things and you know just
about you know the work ethic the
character the things that are so
important I think and life skills that
you get from football and teaching them
some of those things I enjoy that aspect
of it best kid the you saw come through
the Manning passing camp most talented
well you know I we don't we don't keep a
whole lot of tabs on on the campers you
know we've had a couple guys come back
as counselors when they're in college
and a number uh you know Russell Wilson
came as I mean he was in college to be a
counselor that's gonna say oh yeah I was
a camper here
and you know of course my dad's I yeah
yeah we remember you a total total y-you
know and so we don't we don't keep a
whole lot of tabs on the high school
kids you know not you know and so these
high school kids I don't want to throw
any names out right now you know give
these kids too much Club publicity as a
as a sophomore and juniors in high
school but I will say I saw you know
just you know bubby Brister son is a
junior in high school he was there this
year and he could he could you could
throw it you can sling it pretty good
and like old pops I think have you seen
the Jay Cutler reality show I'd have not
I have not I got a check I didn't know
there was one I gotta check it out yeah
well it's about his wife and it's on the
E Network and I'm sure your wife would
love this but it's Kristin Cavallari
it's called very Cavallari but jay
cutler's personality on there is like
you got a tune in it's fascinating when
you're watching Cutler if this is his
real personality he doesn't want to do
anything she wants to stay at home you
know like he'll he'll complain about
everything and I was just fascinated by
it
oh I'll check it out you know it sounds
it sounds right up my speed could you do
reality show if your wife said huh
no I think I think I would be I would be
I think it'd be the most boring thing I
would just I would be you know does not
not want to say they know my wife would
hate it more than I would so no that is
not not in the future okay but what is a
day like with Eli man like what would be
so boring that we would not want to
watch reality show with you well it'd be
like me you know making breakfast I make
a I make a mean oatmeal you know let's
go TV eggs egg Mayo me making some egg
whites I got a good system and I can for
that that's about it you know throw a
little go run go lift some weights and
then you know I throw on my speedo go
swim with the kiddos
not have a speedo no I did not okay yeah
all right yeah we were wondering like
you know that's let's do they do a
reality-tv swimming and you know it's
like the old Ben Stiller meet the
parents you get into the bathroom and
there's just two options you know you
gotta like which one of these swimsuits
am I gonna wear here that's how they
trick you had things who would you be
interested in watching current NFL
quarterback reality show that's I mean I
think Phillip Rivers he's got like you
know he's got eight kids I want to see
how that works he's nine now he like he
just had one yeah had one last hour I
think exactly you know I think that I
want to see how that works I want to see
like the you know the bus you know the
power mall and you know I've known
Philip a long time we came out the same
year with the some sports camps you know
we're I mean I mean in college he came
down to our football camp and I'm 20
years old and and hey we're about to go
to his little dinner and hang out a
little bit you want to go it he's like
well I gotta call the wife and kids and
what you mean your mom right he's like
no no I I'm married I have a kid girl
and I was like whoa too different you
know two different leagues right here
but uh you know a lot of films obviously
been a great player but yeah you know
that that was he's a reality show
Eli Manning joining us from Keene
University in Union New Jersey
participating in an offense defense
football camp on behalf of the 14th
annual Gatorade beat the heat program as
he discusses hydration and heat safety
for athletes staying safe and
maintaining peak performance during the
hot summer months
I saw where your helmet when you beat
the Patriots is up for auction is that
right yeah yes it is what's that gonna
go for I have no idea you know it's it's
uh it's not it's not it's not going to
me he always thought it's not uh oh no
not in my possession so it's not it's
not me putting it up for for sale
because one expert suggested to go for a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
I mean that's a lot that's a lot of
thought okay did you do you have a
favorite piece of memorabilia did you
keep the charger Jersey when you were
drafted I did you know my I think my mom
had it something else for a little bit
and I think she she tried to you know
she's like well we don't need this and
tried to you know giving them human away
to somebody I think my dad you know
wised up and they say you know let's
just hold that on you know hold on to
that for a rainy day might be a good
story so it's in it's in possession so
just you know have that again I don't
know you know know why but have it for a
rainy day how long was that though when
you look back now it was awkward it's
funny you know looking at some of the
pictures for that draft day and just not
many smiles early on and then and then
big smiles kind of 45 minutes later when
we got traded to the Giants oh it was it
was a tough few weeks or a tough few
days kind of leading up to draft and and
you know you never kind of want to be
you know center of attention kind of for
the wrong reasons and and you know it's
supposed to be an exciting time in your
life and get drafted and going and then
it was it was kind of a rough start to
the county your NFL career but you know
I was so happy how it all how it all
worked out how did you find out the
Giants we're gonna take sake one Barclay
you know when when on draft night you
know just watching it watching it live
and that's that's when that's when I
found out and so you know I think I
think you know a lot of there was a lot
of Giants fans cheering you know none
more than my wife jumping up and down
excited that that the Giants took a
running back and so she was she was
excited along with with myself and and
our whole family wait you didn't inquire
you didn't you weren't curious what the
Giants were gonna do you know it's just
kind of a it's a tight it's the same
everybody's got a tight lip during that
time and I think I just you know you
know so you don't know you know exactly
you know what's gonna happen with the
first pick and how it all is going to
play down or trades or this and that so
there's I don't think there's a whole
lot of you know we just don't know how
all gonna play so no one didn't have any
any you know 100% insight what was gonna
go on looks like say Kwan Barclays is in
pretty good shape there he like yeah we
have a similar similar physiques I would
say have you met him you know I probably
squat a little bit more than him but uh
you know but he's still easiest rookie
so I got a few years on him yeah yeah I
met se Kwang you know he was he's been
impressive during our you know kind of
our OTAs and practices and just you know
picking up the offense you know catch
the football I think those running backs
you know you know they're you see how
they run once the pads come on once the
games get started and and you know
making those that first guy miss and
doing those things but he's a great kid
and been impressed with them Gatorade
beat the heat program for more
information on heat illness prevention
please visit the Gatorade youtube
channel enjoy the offseason there Eli
thank you for joining us we appreciate
it thanks Dan have a great one really
appreciate it and see lime inning for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]